does isaiah chapter 56 verse 6 and 7 apply to us
isaiah 56 from 4 down to 7 talks about the the
the eunuch in verses 4 and 5 the son of a stranger
6-7 will all have access to god if they obey god
isaiah 56 is merely describing the universality of
the gospel in other words god accepts anyone who
comes to him god will sanctify anyone who makes
the conditions whether it's a eunuch a non-jew who
comes in and this teaching is not new to isaiah
when god introduced circumcision to abraham which
was the mark of a child of god back then along
with the sabbath when god gave circumcision to
abraham in genesis 17 from verse 22 the bible
says and he left off talking with abraham
and god went up from abraham left off talking
with him and the lord went up from abraham so
god went back to heaven and abraham took ishmael
his son and all that were born in his house
and all that would bother his money all the males
among the household of abraham and circumcised the
flesh of the foreskin in the self-same day as
god had said unto him verse 24 and abraham was
99 years old when he was circumcised in the
flesh of his foreskin ishmael his son was 13
years old when he was circumcised in the flesh of
his foreskin in the self saying they was abraham
sacrificed and ishmael his son and the last verse
says 27 of genesis 17 and all the men of his house
born in the house or bought with money of the
stranger were circumcised with him whether you
were born from abraham whether you were one of the
hebrews or you're from stranger that was bought
at a slave market when you got circumcised you
qualified as a full-fledged child of god and so
we see when circumcision was introduced it applied
to any one circumcised is my child and so isaiah
56 is merely preaching the universality we see
that in john 3 16 for godzilla of the world that
he gave his only begotten son that if the jews
believe they shall have eternal life no whosoever
that's the message in 56 anyone who fulfills
condition is accepted by god acts 10 34 35
then peter opened his mouth and
said of the truth i perceive
that god is no respecter of persons but in every
nation the greek word ethnos we get ethnic group
in every nation he that feareth god and worketh
righteousness is accepted with him any nation
you do what god wants you to do he accepts you
that's the message there in uh isaiah 56 amen
you